hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an american drama thriller film
called hide and seek
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
alison callaway and her nine-year-old
daughter emily callaway
are playing in a park together allison's
husband and psychologist
dr david callaway is there too he
watches them play
at night allison and emily play a game
of hide and seek
after which allison tucks emily to bed
alison seems to be worried about
something
david asks her about it but she
dismisses it
alison then goes to take a bath however
around two in the morning
david wakes up to see allison still not
in bed he goes to check the bathroom
where he is terrified to see allison
sitting on a bloody tub
she had committed suicide by cutting her
wrist emily stands in the doorway as she
watches david hugging alison's body and
crying
cut to a few days later emily is in a
children's hospital and seems depressed
david talks to his colleague and good
friend dr catherine carson
and decides that it would be best if he
and emily moved to the countryside for
some time
catherine is close to emily as well she
hugs emily and wishes her goodbye and
they leave
emily brings her cat with her to the new
place david and emily are finally at
their new home
it lies in an area surrounded by woods
and is very quiet
they are welcomed by a sheriff and the
owner of the house
as they are looking around emily
disappears
they find her near the wood staring at
something that night emily doesn't eat
anything and insists on sleeping early
david tries to cheer her up but the girl
is traumatized by her mother's death
he then gives her a diary to write down
her feelings after which emily wishes
her favorite doll named alex goodnight
before going to sleep
the following day david is unboxing his
belongings in his study room
when emily goes into the woods following
a butterfly in the end
she sees a cave by the time david starts
looking for her
she is back but her favorite toy doll
alex
is not shortly he and emily leave to run
some errands
as david is pumping gas into his vehicle
he sees a woman playing with a little
girl
thinking that the little girl could
become friends with emily he introduces
himself to them
the woman's name is elizabeth young she
seems to have charmed david
he invites them to come over someday
that night while tucking emily to sleep
david asks her about her doll alex to
which she says that she doesn't like her
anymore
she tells him that she has replaced alex
with her new friend named charlie
when david questions her further about
charlie she says that he doesn't like
being talked about
david calls catherine to tell her about
the incident they both agree that
charlie is an imaginary friend
emily has created to cope with her
trauma the following day
david finds alex in the bin with her
face distorted
later at dinner david tries to talk to
her about charlie
at that time she tells him that charlie
is a lot of fun like her mommy used to
be
that night he gets another nightmare he
has been getting the same nightmare of
the new year's eve party that occurred
the night before alison's death
the nightmare wakes him up exactly at
the time he did when alison died
he hears a noise and goes to check in
the bathroom to see the words you let
her die
the bathtub is filled and emily's crayon
lay around
he turns around and sees emily behind
him but when asked about it
emily insists it was charlie who did it
it was charlie the following day
elizabeth and her niece amy come over
david introduces amy to emily but she
seems to have no reaction
as they play amy is eager to become
friends so she hands her doll to emily
but when emily returns it back its face
is distorted like alex's was
emily tells amy that she shouldn't be
here feeling scared
they leave soon after when david asks
emily about amy
she replies she doesn't need any new
friends and that charlie is enough
later emily plays outside as david does
the dishes
he sees a man sitting beside her so he
goes out to check and finds that the man
is their neighbor stephen
they have an awkward conversation after
which david warns emily not to talk to
strangers
cut to that night david hears emily
laugh but when he goes to check on her
she's alone he asks if charlie is here
but emily says that he just left through
the window
david tries to talk to her about charlie
but emily reveals that charlie doesn't
like david
david writes all of this in his journal
after putting her to bed
later we see emily play hide and seek
with charlie
she goes out of her room and look around
the house to look for him
she finds a door behind a closet it
leads to a basement downstairs
she walks there still looking for him
then suddenly the lights go off
and she screams in fear david quickly
comes to get her
she tells him that charlie was hiding in
the dark
the following day elizabeth comes over
for dinner emily doesn't seem to like
her
elizabeth tries to have a conversation
with emily and gives her some books to
read
however emily acts hostile towards her
and drops all the books to the floor
seeing this david demands her to go to
her room soon
elizabeth leaves that night david again
wakes up exactly at 206
there is a noise coming from the
bathroom he goes into check and sees the
words now look what you've done
the bathtub is full of dirty water as
david goes in to drain it
he feels something inside it is the dead
body of the cat that lived with them
furious david goes to emily's room but
emily again insists that it was charlie
charlie did it he then cleans up the
mess in the bathroom
the following day emily shows david
pictures she has drawn of charlie and
her mother
david tries to tell her that charlie is
not real but emily keeps on yelling his
name
that day catherine visits them catherine
is david's good friend who is very close
to emily
emily is very excited to meet her she
suggests david to bring emily back to
new york
he tells her that he will consider it
after she is gone
david goes to emily's room and sees that
she has drawn pictures of her mother
killing herself in the diary he had
given her
elizabeth comes over again that day but
david doesn't hear her knocking
so she comes in and goes into emily's
room she has come to make amends with
emily but emily tells her that she is
playing hide and seek with charlie
and points at the closet as elizabeth
opens the closet
she is attacked by someone and falls
down the windows
after a few hours a sheriff comes over
to ask about elizabeth
the sheriff informs david that he had
found elizabeth's car crash down the
road
and her niece told him that she had come
here but david knows nothing about the
incident
the sheriff then asks emily about her
but she lies and tells him that she
hasn't seen her
after he is gone david senses something
wrong
he sees the window broken emily is
crying hysterically
she shows him the time it is exactly 206
again
david rushes to the bathroom to see some
words written on the shower curtain can
you see now
he opens it and is terrified to see a
dead elizabeth lying in the tub
he rushes back to a crying emily but she
still insists that it was charlie
she says she cannot tell david anything
about him then
david locks her in the room and rushes
out shortly after
we see someone open the door for her
emily then calls catherine to tell her
she doesn't want to play with charlie
anymore
david on the other hand decides to get
rid of elizabeth's body
but when he goes into the bathroom the
body is already gone
emily says that charlie just left with
it this has gone too far
david is now furious and is determined
to find out who charlie really is
he runs outside to search for him
suddenly his neighbor stephen appears
behind him
and demands to see emily because he has
heard noises from their house
david attacks him assuming that this
whole time he is charlie
he rushes back to his home and locks the
doors he tells him to stay away from his
daughter
emily hugs him in fear and begs not to
make her see charlie again
david then walks into his study room
where he is surprised to see that none
of the boxes have been opened since they
moved here
even the journals are blank he is in
shock because he has been in the study
writing his journal several times after
the move
suddenly everything comes back to him we
see that the person emily met at the
cave that day was david
he realizes that he has dissociative
identity disorder and charlie is not
imaginary at all
charlie is david himself whenever
charlie would emerge
david would be in his study he also
finally recalls the new year's eve party
the night before his wife's death
he had caught allison making out with
another guest charlie was created as a
way to express david's rage so that he
could murder his wife
something the docile david was too
decent to do emily knew the entire time
about her father's split personality but
did not tell him because she was unsure
which personality murdered her mother
until charlie killed elizabeth
every time charlie comes out david
doesn't remember anything
when david comes to realize this
charlie's personality completely takes
over him
he tells emily that daddy is gone
luckily the neighbor has called the
sheriff
who comes to check on david he finds
emily in her room when the lights go off
the sheriff goes downstairs to check
however he is killed by charlie
charlie senses that emily doesn't like
him anymore he starts a game of hide and
seek and starts to count
emily rushes to her room just then
catherine arrives
as she moves down the basement charlie
appears behind her and pushes her down
he locks her there where she finds the
sheriff's dead body
emily on the other hand locks herself
inside her room
charlie breaks the door open but emily
has already snuck out through the window
and is running away to the woods
she hides in the cave catherine takes
the sheriff's gun and runs to save emily
before charlie can get to emily
catherine reaches the cave as well
but charlie pretends to be david and
when she lets her guards down
he attacks her again emily stops charlie
from killing catherine by distracting
his attention to herself
as charlie moves closer to kill emily
catherine comes in between them and
shoots him to death
cut to a few months later emily and
catherine have moved back to new york
they live happily now the movie ends as
the camera zooms into emily's drawing of
herself
and catherine where she has two faces
suggesting that she might also have two
personalities like her father
now for the explanation of the movie it
is clear by the end of the movie that
david and charlie are the same person
david has a mental disorder called
dissociative identity disorder which is
ironic because david himself
is a psychiatrist when charlie murdered
allison that night
david was unknown to any of this even
when they moved houses
charlie did not go away every time
charlie arrives
david is seen in his study room writing
or listening to music
but he had never even unboxed his
belongings in that room
even his notebook is empty this suggests
that he hallucinated all of it to avoid
coming face to face with his other
personality
in the movie we also see emily being
hostile she even purposely disfigured
the face of amy's doll
there are three possible reasons the
first reason is that she might do it out
of dislike for amy's aunt
elizabeth second she might do it in
order to frighten amy into staying away
so that charlie wouldn't hurt her
the third possibility is that emily was
displaying the pathological side of
herself
that's my explanation for the movie hide
and seek
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching